ella es una integrante del parlamento
francés y es blanco de racismo con
cadenas alrededor de su cuello en una
revista
d'angelo bueno ha sido retratada en una
historia de ficción de siete páginas
como una esclava el artículo de la
revista conservadora francesa va al ex
actual está siendo condenado en todo el
espectro político francés empezando por
la propia legisladora o 'bono dijo en
redes sociales que la publicación
racista era odiosa estúpida y cruel el
primer ministro francés también rechazó
la historia de la revista y ofreció su
apoyo al igual que manuel macrón quien
llamó a la legisladora sin embargo los
activistas anti racistas dicen que el
propio presidente y su gobierno de hecho
han ayudado a crear una aceptación
progresiva de tal racismo al dar
entrevistas como hizo macro en el año
pasado a la revista considerada de
extrema derecha
emanuel macro ni marlins ya para en el
gobierno francés decidieron dar
entrevistas al ex actual y al conceder
estas entrevistas en realidad
normalizaron estas ideas sin embargo el
radicalismo de extra
la derecha siempre será un radicalismo
de extrema derecha
la revista emitió una disculpa o 'bono
quien está considerando si llevara la
revista a los tribunales por difundir
ideas racistas y extremistas